hello everybody so you see this question
was asking cbse great and maths
examination today and there is a mistake
in the question if you actually make the
figure according to the given
information over here suppose this is
the x-axis this is the y axis this is
the origin the coordinates are d0 comma
zero so B is zero comma zero over here
and C is three comma zero suppose this
point is C and this is 3 comma Z over
here and you want to D 0 comma 4 over
here so you want a rectangle over here
so there is no other possibility but to
take the fourth coordinate over here as
three comma four if you want a rectangle
and if you name it a which is needed in
this question vertex a you see that this
rectangle you'll get and this is
basically coming out to be
or you can name it a c b d you can say
out of these options it is correct but
over here it is ABCD so you can say that
the question is not correct and you can
expect that you'll get one mark from
this question